depuis washington avec tristan kabelo au
maître de conférences en civilisation
américaine spécialiste de l'histoire
afro-américaine
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir bonsoir qui ce temps qu'un vélo
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france aux états unis la vaccination est
en pleine effervescence ans se réjouit
le président baydan annonçant qu'à
partir du 19 avril tous les adultes
américains seraient éligibles à la
vaccination les états unis commencent à
réellement voir le bout du tunnel
oui vous avez tout à fait raison on voit
vraiment le bout du tunnel ici il faut
savoir que tout le monde s'y est mis un
les pharmacies les médecins généralistes
des hôpitaux les employeurs on pouvait
vraiment se faire vacciner à peu près
partout ici aux etats-unis et donc ce
que l'on voit c'est vraiment la fin du
tunnel la fin de cette de cette épidémie
beaucoup de maires ont déjà publié leurs
plans de réouverture pour leur ville la
maire de washington dc a publié son plan
de réouverture juste eu hier et dès la
mi mai il y aura donc les théâtres les
cinémas les salles de concerts qui
pourront réouvrir et puisque l'on voit
aussi c'est vraiment la vie de demain à
vide après beaucoup d'entreprises
demandent maintenant à leurs employés
s'ils préféraient travailler à plein
temps dans distant ciel puisque c'était
le cas durant la dernière année et donc
il ya beaucoup de choses qui se mettent
en place ici mais on voit vraiment la
fin du tunnel
alors effectivement un américain sur
trois qui a reçu au moins une dose de
vaccin la californienne qui rouvre le 15
juin
ce qui est intéressant ça serait de
savoir est ce que ces succès ils sont
attribué à joe biden qui a beaucoup
communiqué sur la crise sanitaire ou sur
donald trump qui a lui fortement misé
sur le vexin quitte à s'attirer les
moqueries parfois j'ai envie de dire ni
l'un ni l'autre un aux états unis
c'est ces entreprises sont complètement
décentraliser c'est à dire que le
gouvernement fédéral finalement avait
très peu à voir avec la logistique l
organisation de la distribution des
vaccins et de la vaccination c'était
vraiment au niveau des états et au
niveau des villes au niveau des
employeurs que ce genre de choses a été
fait maintenant il est vrai que dans la
conscience populaire byden récolte un
peu les bons points de cette bonne
campagne de vaccination alors il ya une
polémique sur la mise en place au nom
d'un passeport vaccinale est ce que vous
pensez que cela pourrait être un nouveau
sujet de discorde entre démocrates et
républicains
nous sommes dans un pays ici où il n'y a
même pas de deux cartes d'identité
nationale en fait donc tout ce qui est
identique à sion au niveau fédéral est
complètement rejeté par les américains
mais il y a en fait ce
ce passeport dati n'a en fait existe en
fait à peu près déjà puisqu'on nous
donne à chaque fois qu on est vacciné
une carte qui est sponsorisé par de 6
d'ici et le gouvernement fédéral qui
tend à prouver que nous sommes donc bien
vacciné je pense qu'il n'y aura jamais
de passeports vaccinale au niveau
fédéral par contre les employeurs et les
entreprises privées pourront demander la
preuve de cette vaccination
lorsque leurs employés viennent dans
leurs locaux les etats unis qui
disposent on le sait de plusieurs
millions de doses d'astrazeneca qu'ils
ne peuvent pas utiliser n'ayant pas
donné l'autorisation d'utilisation mais
qui refuse pour autant d'en distribuer
notamment aux pays pauvres d'ailleurs
même à la france
ce choix de l'administration baden et
est-ce qu'ils aient compris trump ou
byden ça reste l'america faste alors ici
on ne parle pas du tout de ce fameux
vaccin
astrazeneca puisque comme vous le dites
il n'a pas encore reçu l l'approuvent
volant de la f10 y est
mais les trois autres vaccins moderna
pfizer et johnson & johnson sont très
bien accepté par la population est en
fait dans tous les centres de
vaccination
on peut en fait choisir à un tel vaccin
on veut avoir pour notre taxi nation ici
les américains ne parle pas beaucoup du
fait que hayden garde ses doses
d'astrazeneca
au cas où il y aurait des problèmes dans
la vaccination futur mais en tout cas by
donne tout comme trump vous l'avait bien
dit choisi america first est donc ces
doses d'astrazeneca resteront aux états
unis au cas où il y en aurait besoin un
jour ou l'autre
alors il ya une autre actualité j'aurais
d'ailleurs a pris la parole et à
quelques instants il juge un plan
d'investissements indispensables pour
que les états unis restent la première
puissance du monde
c'est un génie qui financent donc ce
plan d'investissement en augmentant les
impôts de leurs sociétés de 21 à 28 %
cela rompt avec une politique de près de
40 années
n'est ce pas alors tout à fait j'ai même
envie de dire peut-être un siècle c'est
à il faut retourner au new deal pour
avoir un taux d'imposition aussi
important alors non seulement byetone va
augmenter des impôts sur des entreprises
dont de 24 à 28 % comme vous venez de
dire mais aussi il va augmenter les
impôts sur les revenus les plus hauts au
dessus de 400 mille dollars par an il y
aura un appeau qui ressemblera un peu à
un impôt sur la fortune
c'est très très surprenant de sa part
puisqu'il faut savoir qu'il avait refusé
le plan d'imposition d'elizabeth warren
qui voulait aussi un impôt sur la
fortune et qu'il a dit qu'il ne
commenterait pas les impôts durant son
mandat
par contre il a aussi fait de grandes de
très grands projets ici un sont rangs de
son plan de sur l'infrastructure est
vraiment énormissime
il coûte très cher le plan de relance va
coûter aussi très cher
est ce cette augmentation d'impôts sur
des entreprises est en
très acceptée par les américains on voit
qu'il y à une campagne de communication
qui est assez bien rodée même des
économistes de droite de fox news se
disent que c'est une très bonne idée en
fait pour la relance du pays
effectivement c'est surprenant et dans
le même temps un joe biden qui veut
pousser ses partenaires internationaux
vers un accord sur un taux international
d'imposition minimal des entreprises
avant de vous faire réagir je vous
propose d'écouter la secrétaire d'état
au trésor américain
nous travaillons avec les pays du g20
pour s'entendre sur un taux minimal
d'imposition sur les entreprises
il pourrait mettre fin à la course vers
le bas ensemble nous pouvons utiliser
une taxation mondiale minimal sur les
entreprises pour nous assurer que
l'économie mondiale prospèrent sur la
base de règles du jeu plus équitables en
matière d'imposition des multinationales
et stimuler l'innovation la croissance
et la prospérité
alors c'est vrai que sur le papier on
attendait pas nécessairement les états
unis en pointe sur ce type de sujet oui
surtout on attendait pas du tout byden
sur ce type de sujet du sqbb hayden
avait fait une campagne tout à fait
modéré qui rejetait vraiment la gauche
du parti démocrate
en dehors du parti démocrate et puis là
on tue ça vient de janet yellen et jaden
diana deviens vraiment complètement du
cera et 1 c'est une vieille
washingtonienne de l'establishment qui
n'a jamais eu vraiment ce genre de
positions avant alors est-ce que encore
une fois c'est une entreprise de
communication pour baden qui essaye de
rassembler son parti démocrate
principalement si la gauche et les
progressistes ou est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui va aller jusqu'au bout
ça c'est assez difficile à savoir
vous vous rappelez qu'il y a quelques
mois au début du mandat il avait promis
des chèques de 2000 $ à tous les
américains
ces chèques ne sont jamais arrivés ils
ont eu 1600 dollars il avait promis
aussi l'université gratuite public de la
santé publique gratuite pour tous les
américains ça ne s'est pas passé donc
est ce que c'est encore une fois une
entreprise de communication ou est-ce
que ce plan en fête se déroulait jusqu'à
sa concrétisation je crois que les
quelques semaines qui arrivent là nous
le diront ea suivra donc merci tristan
bello maître de conférences en
civilisation américaine spécialiste de
l'histoire afro-américaine d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france